hi there steve here
continuing my uh 90 day challenge
today
i didn't do anything i haven't done
anything yet in korean
i listened for about 10 or 15 minutes
while doing the dishes that's about it
um my wife and i are in whistler
we're overnighting here we played golf
today at the big sky
golf course
because we can play there free it's a
reciprocal with our uh course in
vancouver
and tomorrow i'm gonna play golf again
and drive home so i've got to try to get
my
korean in and i think this is an
important point
um the challenge is all about making
sure you commit to a certain level of
activity as i said yesterday so i don't
know what i'm going to achieve but i
know
that when i finish this now it's about
nine o'clock here i've gotta at least
get in an hour
with the korean language like i have to
maintain my level of activity if we
maintain our level of activity
and i enjoy doing it it's just a matter
of finding the time if we're doing it if
we're enjoying it and if we commit to
that time we will get the results so
that's all i want to say uh you saw my
video yesterday uh you know that we went
out with some chinese friends went to a
very nice it's called the beijing
restaurant in vancouver had the beijing
duck
um
i brought my own bottle of wine because
i don't like drinking too much of that
multi
um and so for that reason uh and i have
said that i'm going to do some
uh you know languages in at least give
some videos and languages other than
english so i'll do a little bit of
chinese now
and but then i will do russian because
the first person who asked for
other uh language videos
asked for it in russian and what i'm
going to say you've heard it before i i
don't know when i'll have time to do a
transcript or provide subtitles
that's
foreign